Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
joins us from Capitol Hill senator good
morning good morning to you all I want
to get your reaction senator to align
them from the president last night when
he when he talked about ridiculous
partisan investigations what was your
reaction to the line if there are going
to be if there is going to be peace and
legislation there cannot be war and
investigation well that line like so
much of the speech just was partisan and
self-serving stacey abrams showed the
president what real leadership was last
night she was compassionate she was
caring she talked about the plight of
her family the plight of American family
she knows the American Dream is out of
reach for too many people and fading for
others did you take that particular line
as a threat I took it that the president
scared the bottom line is that we are as
a country we've always had Congress do
oversight over the executive branch
that's how the founding fathers set it
up senator the president also said that
were he not in office we would be at war
with North Korea what is your response
to that and does he deserve credit for
bringing North Korea to the negotiating
table they haven't had a nuclear test or
a missile launch since their first
summit no but the reports are that new
hood North Korea still has its nuclear
weapons that it may be building other
kinds of weapons and proceeding along on
its nuclear pathway it's sort of a
metaphor the president says one thing
and the reality is another he said after
he first met with Kim jong-un that we
you know that we'll have no nuclear
North Korea of course that's not true
senator apprehensions at the border
peaked in 2000 at 1.6 million in last
year it was 400,000 so there are many
less people crossing the border and yet
the president said last night that we
have a moral duty to create an
immigration system that protects the
lives and jobs of our citizens are you
going to get something done with the
president to make sure there isn't
another government shutdown well I think
the president real
that the shutdown that he caused and
bragged about was a failure and for this
president who seemed so impervious to
what's going on in this case I think he
touched the hot stove and he knows it so
the real answer for the president stay
out of it
we've set it up so that Democrats and
Republicans House and Senate can come to
an agreement and keep the government
open and if the president stays out of
it they're very likely to come to a good
agreement senator let me ask you another
question about the border the president
called it a moral issue this question of
illegal immigration and he said no issue
better illustrates the divide between
America's working class and America's
political class than illegal immigration
what was your response to that well on
the one hand he's saying that we have
more jobs than we've ever had before
and on the other hand he's saying
illegal immigration is taking away all
our jobs as usual the speech is just
filled with total contradictions that
don't add up most Americans I think it's
68 percent certainly I and most
Americans believe that immigration is
good for the country we all want to
secure our border but it's not a crisis
it doesn't demand the government shut
down shut down we've got to go but can
you just say yes or no yes okay the
committees are making progress the
president's got to stay out of it we can
get it done
all right Senator Schumer thanks so much
for being us thanks very much good to be
with you